I'm really interested in them terms and
conditions and I don't think most people
know what the terms and conditions are
so when you say terms and conditions
explain to people that typical moment so
they can relive and think I nobody's
talking I think of what's best and most
ridiculously when you try and buy
something off an app store tiny window
will pop up and it will say terms and
conditions do you agree to them and
you'll have page one of three hundred
and twelve and then a button saying
accept and pedak li what appears to
happen is people tend to spend about one
and a half to two seconds between
opening the terms and conditions and
clicking the I accept button say that
again this roughly they spend between
one and a half and two seconds between
having these documents presented to them
and clicking the accept button do you
read the pages because you're like this
expert and you know the pitfalls what do
you do as an individual I am an
individual I do exactly the same as
everyone else and with probably one
caveat and the caveat would be that I
minimize my rest by having little
presence on the web site for example
don't use Facebook don't use Twitter
no one scrolls through those three
hundred note pages or even sends a PDF
no one's got time
they just say yes and they presume
that's okay broadly speaking that can a
buyer beware model is risky and it's
risky as more and more personal
information gets captured and that could
be used for different purposes and in
different ways so I think that we need
to think much more carefully about that
than we do by analogy and last thing you
got a warden what happened I had to fill
out a lot of papers do you remember the
sheet at the at the front which said key
facts do give you like an idiot's guide
yeah we don't and these terms and
conditions so there isn't a kind of key
facts of what you're agreeing to like an
executive so yeah well it's like how
long you know what they can count
with your data who where what there your
rates of withdrawal ah this sounds
really fascinating and it sounds really
important it doesn't feel like computer
science is this computer science or is
this is this sort of interface well I
think the answer that is the computer
science I do and I think it is
fundamentally computer science and I
think it's fundamentally computer
science because because of a notion that
I call responsible innovation if we're
building systems and tools that capture
information off people analyze that
information and make make suggestions
which have profound impacts on their
lives then we have to do this in the
context of understanding their rates and
responsibilities and engaging with them
as individuals as well so part of you
know part of this is is building the
tools to let it happen
so we've constructed a little plugin
that you can get for the Chrome browser
which will look at the terms of
conditions and measure that complexity
for you there's a algorithm called smog
which stands for a simple metric of
gobbledygook now allows you to kind of
get a measure of how complex that takes
there's our heard inside takes this we
were able to then mark that in the UK
context onto M educational attainment
levels so essentially how much education
would you have to have done in order to
be able to read a document that complex
the basic principle of this and is that
what you do is you sample you sample the
start and beginning of a document you
look it's particular measures across
this these long words number of
characters and what are small how long
sentences are how many secondary clauses
they are so what you actually do is you
develop a set of metrics which allow you
to measure those and you combine those
metrics together and normalize them so
that you have a measure which shows you
that these are small sentences with
small ones big complex sentences large
paragraphs with large ones what we found
was that to be able to read the terms
and conditions for an error in this case
for the utilities companies for the
people
supply us all with energy and meant that
you had to actually have had a tertiary
level of education so you need at least
bachelor's degree most likely a masters
or postal level qualification so you
need this in order to be able to
understand the density of that text so
that means that for large segments of
the population they haven't gone they
haven't got a reading level that will
allow them to read that text so
obviously the easy answer is but this is
all legal tapes and you need to be a
lawyer to understand
well actually it's written in such a
manner that it's just hard to follow
okay so the second part of what we did
to this was we we said well how would
people make sense of this and we mark
those then to two books that they may
have read so you know so for example and
boots lake and they will for our de la
vez travels or all of these great
classics of the old field we should have
read we all have purchased them they lie
somewhere on our shelves and because
we've got to through the first two page
and thought this is hard work and we
match them to those and again we found
that that was really quite surprised and
so so you know for example Google's most
recent change of terms and conditions
and you have you know are equivalent in
complexity to be able which very few of
us have managed to read all the way
through there is a complicated book too
complex for me okay and similarly the
number of the bank incites them when the
banking industry runner takes through
this the leaf owned and equivalent to
Nietzsche and again niches and
achievement so the point here actually
is what are we given up when we can't
read the tags to explain what it is that
we've given up and I think part what we
want to try and understand is how people
make meat use of that data and a big
data world and holy mate try and
understand what we're giving up and what
would agree into professor these are
important deals that have been done
though these are complicated concepts
involving money and copyright and
licensing of products I mean these can't
be
cat sat on the mat or are you suggesting
they're deliberately hiding truth behind
so I wouldn't want to suggest a
deliberately hiding truth but to be
honest I think we're all been a bit too
comfortable and a bit too lazy about
what we're doing here
so and and I'd like us to change how we
think about this before legislation has
to happen to meet people change these
things from while watching TV show yes I
know that when someone signs a contract
if they don't know what they were
signing the contract can become null and
void contact if you just clicked after
one and a half seconds you haven't
really made an informed decision indeed
and actually legally whether that even
enforceable in the UK is actually
interesting so though so most of the
stuff is copy and paste from the Midwest
legally however there is a notion of
normal expectancy and most normally
expect and normally sort of trusted and
a lot of what happens in those terms and
conditions are our principal about the
second order rates okay by which I mean
and you saying with a company for
example one of your utility suppliers
and within the terms and conditions
you'll find that they will have the
rates to release your data in particular
ways so they will have so for example
one of the terms and conditions that I
read recently has rates to and supply to
any of the families or to sell the
records of your bills your belt payments
and any additional notes that they may
have made about you okay so so so so
that therefore means that those are kind
of release of information out there then
you don't know of or can't control okay
yes yes as it should and well well it
does me
and I think therein lies actually the
real issue I you know it scares me
because I've got lots of training to
understand what the digital doesn't know
they heard they did it was analyzed my
researchers are actually about people's
work people don't have that rest
perception actually what's and
testing in terms of the legislation
framework that exists at present is
we're undergoing a shift we're
undergoing a shift from the emphasis
been and responsibilities for these
things line with us to them line with
the data hand was to align them with big
business
these are at one point and this has been
contained it but at one point claimed an
algorithm which would with a shared
credit history of two individuals who
were a couple and be able to predict
divorce within two years often before
the individuals himself had an awareness
over delete all your files you run this
algorithm to rewrite all the file
contents and erase them and lo and
behold all the contents are still there